if you identify and dress and behave and
whatever as a trans woman and you end up
in a male prison you would be more more
at more danger there's no question about
that I think most of them are
autogynophiles right so I think it's a
synthetic I don't think that makes
someone vulnerable it's not true what
you said which is these people just want
to be validated as women there are trans
people many of them we've had on the
show who don't want that they just want
to live their life I don't think that's
true Constantine if you're if you have
fake breasts and long hair and call
yourself by by a female name do you
think they don't want to be seen as
women
uh I think they do but that doesn't mean
they're willing to invade your space
they will literally slice the breasts of
a 13 year old girl they will do it
there's nullification
they're sorry clarify what is that
policy what nullification surgery from
the chin down you get rid of your
nipples you get rid of your belly button
you get rid of any external genitalia
male or female and you just have it
smoothed except for your pipe work
like they literally will will dehumanize
your torso I was I was even going to go
to Portland which we had to cancel
because there were credible death
threats wow um do you know who's from
all the organizations which well it was
all antifa there's a man who's actually
a famous model with his top down with
his fake breasts shaking them at Women
shouting saying these hands don't
discriminate I will F you up I ain't
dancing to anybody's tune I I just won't
do it
foreign
[Music]
hey Francis do you like entrepreneurs
not really what do you mean what do you
think would do a trigonometry annoy
people on the internet cause meltdowns
on Twitter and destroyed people with
logic and facts all right stop stealing
my catchphrases it's facts and logic I'm
just saying being an entrepreneur is
against my culture why would I work hard
when I could just lie on the beach in a
sombrero shouting
well for those of you who aren't
Venezuelan you need to check out Rob
Moore the disruptive entrepreneur Rob
Moore has been an entrepreneur for 16
years he's built seven companies written
18 business and investing books and now
he helps create a startup scale-ups and
anyone wanting to build assets income
and freedom for information education
and inspiration Rob has reached millions
of people to be disruptive entrepreneurs
and turn their passion into their
profession as well as Instagram access
to Rob's number one ranked disruptors
podcast with the world's most disruptive
guests and billionaires he's also giving
away a digital Financial toolkit to help
you save half your salary and cost in a
year plus keynote talks on building
digital assets and multiple income
streams digitally go now to bit Dot
be quick because this isn't usually free
it's all at bit.ly Rob toolkit and you
will then be directed to the disruptors
podcast plus all this great info will
help you destroy people with logic and
facts
I give up
hello and welcome to trigonometry I'm
Francis Foster I'm Constance and kitten
and this is a show for you if you want
honest conversations with Fascinating
People well it doesn't get any more
fascinating than the guest we have
returning for you today for the third
time she holds the record for our most
viewed interview ever Kelly J King
welcome back to trigonometry oh thank
you so very much it's good to have you
back as you can see we're building our
new studio at the moment and you've been
traveling in the US we haven't really
had a chance to pay too much attention
to what's been going on but yeah
unbelievable from us
um how are you I'm really good yeah
really really good so what what Mischief
have you got up to in the US then
so I decided to do a tour
um and it started in La went up to San
Francisco
um Seattle Chicago Austin and then East
Coast
and it was called let women speak and it
really is just creating a space in which
women feel that they can speak about
what's happening in America which is
insane
that doesn't sound controversial at all
it's
um I knew I had to do it because it's
the belly of the Beast right
um so I was I was even going to go to
Portland which we had to cancel because
they have a credible death threats wow
um do you know who from or what
organizations which well it was all
antifa okay this particular guy was uh
raising money to uh buy some weapons
um yeah and we I mean other parts of our
events we have people that you could
have reinforced
um gloves on
um
a wow long story like a woman got her
fingers crushed and broken uh
they in it was just yeah anyways going
back to the story
um it's it's about the numerous women
and we're making a documentary so the
idea is to record The Descent because
the most known documentary against this
stuff is by a man who I'm grateful that
he's done it but it is embedded in part
of his other kind of agenda
um and I want this to be a women's story
because it's our language that's being
erased it's our bodies and I know the
children is a huge issue but
um I don't want another episode in human
history to pass Us by when it's the
story of women
[Laughter]
but tell us more about it so for people
joining us who are less familiar with
you than we are you're a woman's rights
campaigner we had you on the show I
think back in 2019 or 2020 probably 2019
uh when you you sort of very
articulately talked us out of some of
the let's say sort of inherited views
that many people have about the issue of
transgender rights and the conflict
between that and women's rights and the
safety of children so you go to America
to to give to talk basically about this
issue yes and what happens
um so it's a it's a jump off from uh the
speaker's Corners uh speaker Corner
events I do every month the last end of
every month and we've started to do them
around the UK and America's massive so
what happens is I say I'm going to be
somewhere I work with an organizing team
local organizing team of women
um they get permits if they need them
sometimes we just do gorilla talks which
means we just turn up and hope we don't
get moved uh and women who feel that
they can come out do come out
um it's not huge in number
uh but then um I've got my documentary
guy with me
um and you're just given the microphone
and you talk there is no political
affiliation uh there's nothing that you
can't say besides what is that whatever
is illegal in the location that you're
at
so you know that brings with it certain
other risks but it really is genuine
Free Speech tested genuine free speech
and we don't seem to have that tradition
as much in this country do we no
although speakers Corners go but now
it's just populated by people talking
about God of different varieties
so we do
I did it because I recognized that women
in the modern Public Square which is
social media were censored all the time
we just can't talk I'm sure I've
mentioned it before I'm banned from
mumsnet Twitter I can't advertise on
Facebook I can't advertise on Instagram
my Posey Parker account got banned from
Facebook my Eventbrite events have been
taken off because I hateful I can't sign
a change.org petition you know I'm
censored from everywhere so we Kelly if
I am a random person watching this
conversation I haven't come across you
before maybe haven't come across
trigonometry before what are these
hateful things that you're saying
exactly that women don't have penises uh
that men don't have vaginas no man gives
birth
um that women's anatomy is to be named
properly
um and I don't want euphemisms I don't
want we're not menstruators we're women
um it's protecting the language around
women
um and not using any of that language
for men so there's no such thing as a
trans woman there's just a man
um there's no such thing as non-binary
it's just a very special person
um and so it's that sort of stuff it's
saying that we shouldn't transition
children so everything that's
every part of our language and narrative
that's being co-opted by this
transgender ideology is something that I
want to take back let's see and remember
when we did our first ever interview one
of the we had a lot of back and forth uh
and I think it's fair to say both
Francis and I have come much closer to
your position since then which is to
your credit but also the one issue that
I still feel that every time you talk
about it is what
is it not look it's a conflict between
the rights of different groups is that
what's going on here
right yeah you're not comfortable saying
it like that well
[Music]
yeah let's leave it yes okay
yeah why why the hesitation around that
well because I feel it's a conflict it
sort of imagines that there are two
positions of equal value no not
necessarily equal value but just two
different positions and there are some
people who hold this position and some
people are disposition yes and this
group has certain rights that it wants
to have and this group has certain
rights that it wants to have and they're
in conflict with each other so to make
it very simple if I am a trans man trans
woman right used to be a man
transitioned and I want to go into a
women's toilet there are women in there
who may not want me in there right
that's the conflict yeah right
but what I never understood about your
position I still don't understand is
would it not just be a lot easier to say
a trans woman is not a woman
which I agree with but why do we have to
be so insistent that they're men as
opposed to just going it's a trans woman
and it's a different category and we can
talk about what rights they have and
don't have
can we not make that accommodation let
me walk you down there sorry please
friendly path
so when you use female language for men
even when you put trans women in front
of it you put that man as a category
a woman and he loses the identifiable
kind of everything that comes with being
a man right and so that's why we're here
having this discussion in the first
place that's why I just got stopped at
the train station by someone talking
about her trans women friends it's
because we've confused people by
pretending that they're not men and that
they are something else well then
they're categorically men
um for everything that's important and
essential whether it's uh their
mortality
um whether it's their DNA whether it's
their behavior their propensity to
commit crime
um the way they make women feel
they are men that's why
and what would you say to those people
who are saying that this category are
vulnerable this trans women category
that are vulnerable therefore there
needs to be some kind of special
dispensation look you know it doesn't
you know maybe not entering women's
spaces which is I agree with you on that
but also as well
can we really treat them as men and put
them in so for instance a male prison
isn't that dangerous for them
see now we get to a point where I think
I don't know if I care too much and I
don't know if I agree with the argument
that they are vulnerable I think if you
if you're a man and to go outside of
your house you stick on a dress in a bag
wig I I just don't see where you're
vulnerable let's pretend that I think
but you would be vulnerable in a Men's
prison but you would but why would you
do it we'll do what but if you have a
choice why would you do it well the
argument would be that these people
that's how they feel right so they don't
have a choice that's how they are well
I'm a woman I genuinely feel like a
woman and yeah I'm wearing trousers and
a t-shirt
no but that's not the argument the
argument is if you if you identify and
dress and behave and whatever as a trans
woman and you end up in a male prison
you would be more more at more danger
there's no question about that would you
be more danger in more danger than maybe
an autistic man in a man's prison
probably yes I don't think you would
I genuinely don't think you would I
think there's many vulnerable people in
male prison populations yeah
um which is why the suicide rate is so
high
um and the rates of violence is so high
and I don't think that those men are any
more vulnerable or in need of uh
consideration and certainly not putting
them into a women's prison there is
there is not a point at which I wasn't
suggesting that no neither was I okay
the argument then but you mentioned
um women's prisons or not putting them
in male prisons is that right well yeah
but I didn't say I I didn't say put them
in women's prisoners so my argument and
I think is constantiness as well is that
this is a very small subcategory of
people who maybe they shouldn't have
access to females faces but maybe they
need their own spaces if you see what I
mean yeah that's where I would come as
it from okay so you say that for
instance there are some people who just
put on a wig and a badly fitting dress
but there's also men who take you know
who have transitioned surgically they've
taken the hormones they're not
are they completely men yes if I if I
bring my cat in now and I cut all her
legs off and her ears and her tail she's
still a cat
I agree biologically it should probably
be more vulnerable yeah
well if I try to throw her out of a
small window yeah
um okay let's do Let's do let's go along
with your idea that these men are
vulnerable I would I really don't know
if I agree and let's say that I think
most of them are autogynophiles right so
I think it's a sexual fetish I don't
think that makes someone vulnerable but
even if I even if I decided that some of
them had gender dysphoria
whatever that might be
um
do I think we should campaign well I'm
certainly won't waste any time doing it
but do I think there should be campaigns
um that offer a solution Beyond Chuck
them in with women and let them use
women's spaces absolutely
is that what any of them want
definitely not what they want is to be
validated as women so part of their
whole kind of I need these the rights
that I need is to force everybody else
to lie and see myself as I see myself
Kelly you're talking in generalizations
I mean Debbie hates and who we've had on
the show who is a trans woman yes she
made the point that you're making
actually which is I shouldn't be in a
women's space because women would be
uncomfortable with me there what the
government needs to do is maybe in this
very specific instance provide some kind
of special facility where people like me
can go because I'd be
scary to women in the women's prison and
I probably would be quite vulnerable in
a mouse person right and you know how
much I like it don't you but I think
this is where sometimes people think and
we've talked about this off camera
people think you're angry when I don't
think you are or hateful when I actually
don't think you are but
when you say well I won't waste any time
or I don't care about these people or
whatever and you're talking these quite
broad brush strokes and you put a lot of
people into the same category and
actually just like in any other group of
people whether it's women or men or
trans or whatever there are people who
see things differently right so do you
I'm just urging you to have a little bit
more Nuance if you will okay so Debbie
hating that you um happily mentioned has
written about him being an autogonophile
so he's he's written that he also right
wrote guidance that put boys into girls
spaces in schools so um and you can find
out I was no but but let's talk about
the argument rather than uh attacking
the person so my argument is not
everybody wants to not everybody who's
trans is desperate to get into a woman's
prison I mean most people aren't
desperate to get into any prison
right
so it's not true what you said which is
these people just want to be validated
as women there are trans people many of
them we've had on the show who don't
want that they just want to live their
life I don't think that's true
Constantine if you're if you have fake
breasts and long hair and call yourself
by by a female name do you think they
don't want to be seen as women
uh I think they do but that doesn't mean
they're willing to invade your space in
some way no but the the person that you
mentioned and probably everybody else
you might have had on the show who calls
himself a woman who isn't definitely has
used women's spaces and 100
and so
I can
I can bypass some of the maybe happy
soft feeling Humanity
um of some of these people because my
goal is to just keep them all out of
women's faces
and I don't know if I care about their
intentions I don't think that's any of
my business I don't care if it's
nefarious or just Jolly or they don't
want to invade women's space is fine
years ago we weren't talking about this
because there wasn't anybody like
habitually using women's spaces I wasn't
it wasn't an issue for me before what
2015 I had no idea that this was
happening but once I'd heard it was
happening and getting so much worse and
I've come back from a country where
women were trying to talk I couldn't
even get to my own event the police
would not help me get there safely I was
late to it because there were 60 at
least police officers in New York City
there's women penned caged in trying to
speak
there's an assault live on air where a
woman gets her hair pulled by a man call
himself a woman
there's there's a man who's actually a
famous model with his top down with his
fake breasts shaking them at women
shiting saying
um these hands don't
um discriminate I will F you up to women
right
[Music]
these cities are more real than you
would ever be [ __ ] I got bodies
it's very ladylike Behavior your tits
out and threatening people I mean it
does sound like Croydon on a Saturday
night I have actually seen that it's
kind of the ammo of many a female but
so I have to focus on
those men I can't be thinking there's
there's no Nuance to societal rules when
it comes to these specific safeguarding
safety things we've made our minds up we
know that some of you men are lovely but
we don't want you in our space and we
don't care how you feel about that
um it's a done deal
I mean one is put like that I think
that's fair enough
um I suppose the the circle I'm or the
square I'm trying to circle the circle
I'm trying to square is whatever we may
think about it the fact is that there
are trans people right and we're going
to have to reckon with that one way or
another so I I perfectly understand the
point you make I'm just wondering if
given that that is a reality that we
have to deal with if there's another way
A Better Way perhaps to to rise slightly
to look at a slightly bigger picture and
go what would be the constructive way of
dealing with this you know because you I
understand uh I'm I I'm someone myself
who feels strongly about certain
principles and sticking up for them as
you know and when you're sticking up for
a principle it's always very natural to
be like this is the way it is no not not
one step back in the words of the Great
Hero Joseph Stalin right
um but
ah
what's my step back that doesn't cost
women and girls I'm not saying that
there is I'm I'm saying maybe there is
this step up where we just look at it at
a bigger picture like the the third
prison suggestion for example right
that's a way of recognizing that look
you want to call a man fine they want to
call themselves trans women fine we have
a special place where you go if you've
committed a crime do you know what I
mean and that's a way of not affecting
your rights it's also aware of not
affecting their rights and everybody is
unhappy
what any of these people are looking for
I mean you know maybe uh not the
campaigners and the activists and the
The Advocates like the individual the
individual rapists that goes to a prison
maybe he's looking for a third space
but I mean that's what we're talking
about we're talking about
especially prisons we're talking about
people in a small environment
um caged in in America we had a woman in
Hollywood she called from an LA Prison
from the inside
um and talked about what it was like and
these men are in their cells with them
um an American president
pretty tough anyway you have to do as a
woman if you have to go to court a lot
or you're in isolation or whatever you
basically have to do cavities they have
to do cavity searches where there's like
50 women at a time and you have to pull
yourself apart and you have to cough and
all this stuff so it's
put a man into that I mean that it's
degrading humiliating vile
and then on top of that
you've got a man who will then rape
you as an inmate and this particular
girl thought because she'd
annoyed one of the staff
um that's why she got a man in her cell
that's awful obviously so third third
spaces yeah if people want to campaign
for it and there's money go for your
life
just not women's faces that's fair yeah
that's fair so uh look uh one of the
things we talked about before
you're giving me the smile but we always
have this debate and I think I think
people should particularly people who
like and respect each other because
otherwise it's all kind of you know
there's the the turfs and then there's
the tras and they're all talking just to
themselves and there's no genuine
discussion right I think it's important
I do too enjoy this discussion
hey Francis do you like Scottish
Wildlife yeah I love Glasgow on a Friday
night no you idiot I mean Scottish Birds
Oh you mean more Rags nah we're not
seeing each other anymore
if you do love Scottish natural
woodlands and the wildlife then you have
to check out established titles they're
selling one square foot of dedicated
land with a unique plot number on a
private estate in edelston in Scotland
and an official certificate with a Crest
established titles is a fun and novel
way to preserve the natural Woodlands of
Scotland whilst helping Global
reforestation efforts it's a Project
based on a historic Scottish custom
where landowners are referred to as
leads the Scottish call them leads
because they can't spell Lords it's the
whiskey I'm gonna ignore that they plan
a treat with every order and work with
global Charities one tree planted and
trees for the future to support Global
reforestation efforts you could
officially include the title Lord or
lady on your credit card plane tickets
dating profiles Etc it makes a great
last minute gift unless you're a
socialist and you want the aristocracy
abolished average titles is actually
running a massive early Black Friday
sale right now plus if you use a code
trigonometry you get an additional 10
off go to established titles.com
trigonometry to get your gifts now go to
established titles.com trigonometry and
get 10 off this wonderful gift
[Music]
hello Stavros this is Lord Foster of
Croydon mate yes what I want Kebab salt
and pepper extra chili sauce salt and
vinegar on the chips what do you mean
you're shot I'm a lord you should always
be open for me
foreign
[Music]
when we went to America one of the
things we came away with was the sense
that
on some issues the United States is
doing a lot better than we are and I
think free speech is genuinely one of
them like in comedy for example the
situation is not as bad over there as it
is over here in our yes in our
experience people you know we went to
Rogan's Club in Austin like the jokes
they were making there you wouldn't be
able to do that in the UK right so
that's fine
but on this issue
I think they're way behind the UK I mean
we're known as Turf Island here right
have you found that is that what's your
impression it's so bad it's so bad
um
they will literally slice the breasts of
a 13 year old girl they will do it they
will do it in Oregon without parents
consent at the age of 15.
there are girls at 18 who've had
hysterectomies there's it's
horrifying there's nullification surgery
sorry clarify what is that Posey what
nullification surgery that means from
from here
from the chin down you get rid of your
nipples you get rid of your belly button
you get rid of any external genitalia
I'm male or female and you just have it
smoothed except for your pipe work like
they literally will will dehumanize your
torso but
why it's progress mate relax
because they can no no I I know I know
that's the answer but I mean why what
what's what's the ideology behind it
what does that signify that to me isn't
a sex change that's something completely
other and
I think it's like an avatar I think you
become an avatar I think I think
transhumanism is a is a something that
sounded too Bonkers uh a few years ago
and I think it's really real that people
are trying to
uh get rid of the human from their
bodies is it is that a kind of
non-binary thing where you just say well
I'm neither male nor female I am this
separate category so therefore I am
going to remove everything is that what
it is I suspect it is I mean non-binary
surgeries especially well for girls all
the time they have their breasts removed
I mean there's such a war on breasts and
they'll just have one scar like no
nipples just one big fat Scar from one
side to the other it's
it's just when you mix
um Godlike surgeons
with
seeing amounts of money
and a a population that let's face it
it's gone through the opioid crisis it's
not a population that is
um
uh particularly
um averse the medical treatment thanks
so much I couldn't think of the word of
us
um but they they love it they they put
their kids in counseling like at age 10
um they they are infantile when it comes
to Parenting they're losing so many of
their parent rights it's I went to a
rally of a woman that went viral for
speaking and speaking at a parent's
rights uh but speaking about parents
rights in a school board and you had
some I did stand in front of all these
American flags I looked like I was about
to announce my presidency
um but I went and talked to her she was
great very religious
um but you had her and then over there
you had teachers just talking about
their right to have more money which I
know is important teaching is great but
it was just very interesting they're
talking about safeguarding their kids
and how they want schools to teach their
children properly and the teachers are
just going oh we would just like some
more money
it was interesting but yeah the um there
is something about
the American
completely especially the Democrat
who doesn't seem to be very grown up
you know they don't even have a good
holiday for their when they work
it's it's a very interesting
kind of powerless situation where people
feel this weird sense of Power with guns
and
um free speech and so on but
for me it felt a lot less powerful as an
individual than it does here
Kelly do you think in many ways it's
kind of the dark side of the American
dream I mean if you can be anything that
you want to be I mean that is the
American dream you go to America you
live in America you you have this chance
you have the dream then surely
maybe it is maybe it says you can be
anything
including like
something catastrophic like maybe that
is the freedom that they've asked for
but
the trouble is when when it's just the
money and it's just kids in medicine
like I don't even agree that surgeons
should be it should be ethically
acceptable for surgeons to make women's
breasts like skin stretchingly massive
um or that you can make someone's ass
like so they can't fit in trousers I
think those things are quite
um unethical but
heads it's like and it's so many kids in
hospitals up and down the country they
are slicing the breasts off of these
girls and
it's um
it's just Butchery and barbarism and
insanity
the thing that always baffles me about
this is it goes against every parental
Instinct literally the the primary
parental Instinct that everybody has is
protect the kids I'm going to protect my
kids from physical danger so the fact
that they then put them into this system
where they become medicalized at such a
young age they get operated upon
non-necessary operations very serious
plastic surgery
um Chico this doesn't make sense this is
it's a kind of Luna suit and these
people will have organic food in their
cupboard right and then they'll Rush
down to do the fifth covered vaccine or
they'll uh put them on puberty blockers
nothing wrong with covert vaccines
YouTube Just make that clear
sorry carry on but it I think it's
I think it's it almost has to be on
purpose
this kind of cognitive dissonance
um
just this I don't know there's
I don't know how to express it but there
is a feel of
um I guess it's the cuddling of the
American mind right there is a there is
a feel of that in many places and the
people that don't feel like that are
called stupid and uh xenophobic racist
ignorant Americans and everybody else is
a little bit on board
um so
uh I've got a cameraman who didn't
really know much about it and um
and he saw Blue's Clues so Blue's Clues
is a kids cartoon of animals and it's
terrible but it's a dog called Blue I
think and he sort of helps the kids and
there was a cartoon of a pride parade
for you know preschoolers because that's
what we want for our kids headed up by a
drag queen and on one of the Pride
Parade floats was a child beaver
I don't think this is a mistake
um with a double mastectomy two scars
four kids a beaver a little Beaver like
so there might be pandas and bears and
whatever all the characters in this
cartoon with a mastectomy a beaver
why does a beaver need a mastectomy
because they're a trans kid in the
they're a transplant a trans Beaver
right I thought it was an interesting
choice of character to do that too to be
honest
um but yeah this transmission is like
what what and then about two minutes
later he goes checked on Snopes it's
real I was like I just shouldn't do I
just showed you it's of course it's real
like it's yeah so that that they're
grooming these kids into this I don't
even know who ultimately benefits or
whether it's like Jennifer bealek has
written in a very um well-researched
article about where the money's coming
from and who makes it well there's money
in in doing the surgeries and giving the
drugs and everything and then there's
ideology and then there'll also be
parents who you know Francis talks about
how well this goes against every
Instinct but I think the hammer they
clobber them with well if you don't do
this your kid's gonna commit suicide I
think and that's how they get you yeah
and actually even if you know that isn't
true
your friends might not talk to you
anymore yeah the school might not talk I
might do it uh behind your back and
change your kids pronouns
um the councilors doctors everyone
everywhere you look for help
they basically tell you you're wrong
and so and you can even get your kids
taken away yeah and are you pleased with
therefore with the progress relatively
speaking that we're making in the UK you
know the changes to the gender
recognition act the shutting down of the
Tavistock and the fact that people are
suing them for malpractice and so on
yeah we've had a few wins in the UK on
this issue yeah I'm happy to say that
I've had a little bit to do with some of
them
um uh the Tavistock uh we put some
people in the House of Lords who then
started working
um with other people uh that's about as
much as I can say
um so yeah there's there's some
significant momentum but that's because
we didn't let it go that far to begin
with and that's because you had women on
all different sides of the political
aisle
um who are willing to speak up obviously
the women on the left aren't willing to
work with anyone else but they are still
willing to speak
um so on that point actually since I am
playing bad cop again come on uh I mean
one of the things that happened during
your U.S trip was quite a lot of
left-wing women who would agree with you
I think on some of the issue underlying
issues uh
were critical of you for uh they were
suggesting that you were associating
with the wrong people and they didn't
even mean us the people worse than us
um so there was some suggestion that
there were proud boys at your events and
all of this what are you to that well I
was relatively proud myself it was great
proud girl yeah
um I think that was an ex-pry boy uh one
or two of the events but it's a free
speech event anyone is invited
um the trouble is that what they want is
they basically want me to take the knee
they want me to disavigne people they
want me to comment on what women say
um and I'm just not doing it I'm not
going to disavide them uh it's none of
my business they're not anything to do
with me I'm not associated with them
it's a free speech event I'm not going
to start playing the disadvant
disassociate nonsense game because then
what happens is what if I don't
disadvise someone then I'm immediately
assumed to have a proper Association so
I'm just not going to do it they can
basically whistle for it which they have
been for about four years the most
merciless Relentless vile
consistent attacks have been from women
on the left
it's just I just felt like going just
get a hobby love like just if you want
to make me irrelevant and you want to
make people stop listening to me do
something better I dare you because then
I I become nothing
but they know I think they know that
can't be done
um and that makes me probably sound as
arrogant as they loathe me for because
I've worked very hard
to make sure that what
I offer with my events is a genuine
space for any woman to speak and men but
mostly women
and I don't think that there's anything
more powerful than people just being
able to scream Into The Ether about the
like insane amount of Silence they've
had to endure because they can't speak
and what do you mean but that they can't
speak where can't they speak at their
jobs sometimes in their own homes I met
women in America who said
how do your kids get on with that I
can't I can't talk about this in front
of my daughter like I'm really worried
she knows I'm here
so how old is she like 14 I was like
you're scared of your 14 year old
daughter
I met loads of women like that it's not
unusual and in this country I mean
teenagers can be vicious
part of the problem what you've just
said right there is that people are
intimidated by their children yes and
that is and that is a real part of the
problem whereby essentially a child can
railroad an adult into making a
disastrous decision that is going to
negatively impact them both emotionally
psychologically biologically for the
rest of their life at 100 I couldn't
agree with you more it's um I sort of
figure my role as a parent
is to raise my children to the a place
in adulthood where they can live on
their own and when they're little you
think I never want them to move out but
when they're teenagers you think I I
love you very much it's uh you're really
building up to be someone who should
leave
but and and you want that for them
because life is amazing uh when it's
your life and and you make your
decisions so that's my job as their
parent
I don't care if they like me
I don't care if they like me at all I
don't I don't need them to think that
I'm anything other than someone who will
be there when they need it and will not
take any crap
um you know and loves them properly
loved like any parent I know would we
die for our kids
so and everything I do I see through the
lens of how I love my children like
that's that's my whole that's everything
that I do but
frightened of them no not in a second no
and the other part of the problem and
I'd be interesting to get your opinion
on this is isn't it also as well and you
see I used to sit with teachers all the
time they want to be their kids friends
yeah
all right
thank you mate I know one of my teachers
asked me out for a drink
I think it was probably something else
yeah
yeah I was about 17 he was like why
don't you come to the pub I was like oh
no
um yes well yeah I think teachers maybe
if you're in the profession too long and
that's the only thing that you've done
maybe you forget that you're 20 years
older or even 10 or the adult in the
room but I also I mean parents as well
parents who want to be friends with
their kids they dress up like the exact
same way and then they go out together
on a night out and you think isn't that
part of the problem as well that nobody
wants to be the adult in the room
because Being the adult is unpopular
because you have to make difficult
decisions well and when you say parents
when you say parents I think you're
being very kind because I think it's
mothers yeah
um that's how I think a more likely want
to be mates I think dads can be
irresponsible children with their
children and often want to be fun but I
think it's I think it's mothers more
than fathers who are going along with
their stuff and don't want to be
disliked and I'm telling you there's
pretty much nothing you can do
as a mother if you've got a teenage
teenagers to make them like you I think
the more you try the more it fails and
those kids need those boundaries we feel
safe with boundaries like my daughter if
I say to my daughter when you're rude to
me it really doesn't make me feel better
very nice she'll go oh it's it's all
about you isn't it
and I'm like in so many ways I respect
that
so Kelly coming back to this idea of
disavower It's Always interesting to me
because I always do feel the
I I cringe when people associate
themselves with me or with our brand or
what we're doing who I don't like and
whose views I think are abhorrent for
example and I I have been quite careful
about making that clear to to my
detriment it means I've not got
relationships with people or I've pissed
people off or whatever um
to me that trade-off is worth it why are
you
um adamant that you you don't want to at
least say well look you've said this
thing that's your Free Speech but
actually I you know I don't agree with
you and I'd rather you weren't here
because if somebody stood up on my
platform and said something that I
didn't agree with yeah then I'm at that
moment I might do it okay
um if somebody says something who's been
on my platform as a free speech thing
and then they say something else
I don't want to undermine everything
they've said hey I probably don't want
to draw attention to it I don't see how
that is valuable for the message that
we're trying to get out
um but I just I won't stand against
these women who have decided that they
are going to speak up because there's so
many that don't and maybe they're
perfect women but they ain't standing up
and speaking so they're not moving this
forward to a point where our children
are safe and women are safe in in their
own spaces
but also I ain't dancing to anybody's
tune I I just won't do it and the more
somebody demands that I do it I'm just
not doing it I just think who are you to
tell me that I should do this oh she
hasn't done this if she could just stand
up and disavide this person and or if I
can just take if I can just take that
one comment that that woman made on your
live stream and I can flip it up and I
can take it out of context and make you
look really bad will you disavow it no I
won't no it's not going to happen it's
interesting because that was what a lot
of people were demanding from us when we
had Sam Harrison
you know go out and slam him for saying
the stuff that I mean we didn't agree
with it and it was quite clear from the
interview why do we have to then go out
and you know go yeah yeah Sam's an idiot
I mean we did an interview make up your
own mind do we want people to speak or
not yeah and and if we do do we then
want to chastise them for everything
they've ever said I mean I just get it
all the time
um there are some women that are rapidly
obsessed with me uh it's it's but I mean
I mean look there's plenty of men
um but you know just really obsessively
weird there was there was um
there was a woman on mum's net and it's
been said elsewhere that I went to an
elite boarding school in Hong Kong
playful by my grandparents where I met
my husband who was married and stole him
from his wife
none of that's true
um just just really Bonkers stuff said
about me
um and it's by the same people that
start these rumor Mills like let's say
we did have a pride boy so what how do I
know what I know about Pride boys is
even true how do I know how do I know
anything is true according to
um even the New York Times I'm a racist
bigot David Duke fan
um I've I've married Richard Spencer in
another life you know just
all these things are said about me and I
know they're not true how on Earth could
I possibly rely on
information about other people
um I'm just and I'm not going to fall
into that and let's say all of those
things were true and that pride boy came
to that thing and listen to me speak
what harm is that to me let's say he's
got a daughter who comes home and at 13
and says she's trans
maybe the the all the goodness in that
exchange comes from me into him and his
life is better for it I'm not changed
because he's heard me speak
hey Francis if you were a member of the
public would you like the opportunity to
ask incredible guests like Bill Burr
Jordan Peterson Sam Harris Adam Carolla
Brett Weinstein John Barnes Douglas
Murray Nigel farage and Lionel Shriver
your own questions you bet I would and
what do you think the best way to do
that would be uh probably stalking mate
you'd have to Corner them in the
supermarket probably brand near like the
sort of frozen food of and then just
bought questions at them before they can
escape uh not the American ones as they
have guns and you'd have to be extra
careful with the females as that's how I
got in trouble last time do you really
imagine you're gonna get Douglas Murray
near the frozen food aisle if you want
to ask our incredible guest questions
and have access to phenomenal behind the
scenes content then you have to be on
our locals that's right for only seven
dollars a month you get incredible extra
content behind the scenes footage
giveaways and also the chance to be part
of an incredible Community where you can
meet and hang out with like-minded
people you get access to our American
Vlogs as we travel across the country
interviewing Our Heroes an extra 20
minutes of our viral Sam Harris episode
as he discusses his approach to covert
we're also going to start doing
giveaways of exclusive trigonometry
merchandise like this a poster from our
Edinburgh show signed by both of us and
also a House of Lords Teddy which you
can only get in the House of Lords
signed by the one only baroness Fox
locals also gives you access to an
incredible online community you can
share memes talk about the latest
episode or even make a new friend or
just one exactly more than both of us
have really people are now doing meetups
in their City because they love locals
in fact some people enjoy it so much
they prefer it over the show they prefer
locals to trigonometry
if I have to get them executed I'm the
one that goes to jail right go to
trigonometry.locals.com only seven
dollars a month for all that incredible
content
trigonometry.locals.com See you there
guys
Kelly
let's look at it broader societally what
do you think this craze says about us as
a society about the Western World the
way that we live
well I I don't want to say it but maybe
we need a war
um
maybe we've just got yeah well maybe
we've got too much maybe we've
um there's a part of me that thinks the
collective kind of uh forward
uh belief of religion and faith and
community
maybe it means the void is filled by
something maybe we are human
the fact that there are so many
religions and creation stories in every
single part of the world tells me that
it is a human necessity to create
answers that we don't know the um
that we we don't know the answers to
answers answers to the questions yeah
thank you so much I'm very tired sorry I
feel like I'm over helping him no no
it's great
um I'll take that help uh but maybe
that's what we need in order to function
and we've had Collective belief before
so there's there's something in that
well those things are disappearing I
mean I'm wondering if at the end of all
of this chaos will come Islam I'm
wondering if that will be a prescriptive
religion that people will be looking for
something really tight on boundaries
because we've lost them
um so I think that's one thread of it
and the other is luxury because if
you're not worried
you know a guy doing scaffolding
let's say
he's not worried about
in his moments of like climbing up and
screwing stuff and whatever he's not
worried about how he identifies
um and so
I don't know maybe maybe people feel
like they need some sort of civil rights
movement to be validated but like Jordan
says tidy your room like sort your own
life out rather than displacing what you
need to sort out with some bigger
picture stuff that isn't even a thing
and one thing that some other people
have suggested is maybe a third thing to
add and I'd be curious to hear your
opinion about it because I think you're
very sound actually on this issue
um is I mean even hormonally speaking
Society is becoming less masculine over
time right men's testosterone is going
down women are much more vocal and
present in public life now obviously we
don't approve all that but you know
sorry
but you know what I mean right Society
is becoming more feminized and you you
can think that's a good thing or you can
think that's a bad thing or you can be
neutral about it but it is happening
would you agree
I do worry about
uh men and I don't spend a lot of time
on that but yes yeah and some of the
this values that drive some of these
social movements they are quite
obviously stereotypically more feminine
than they are masculine when because
they're based on things like empathy and
compassion and you know all of that
taken to an extreme where they become
quite damaging actually
um and I just wonder whether to some
extent the fact that we so prize
compassion and empathy to to an extreme
that's dangerous is maybe a product of
the fact that Society is readjusting to
a new dynamic between men and women
um and you I mean you said it yourself
it's mothers that that often behave in
this way right
um are there just too many women around
yeah
um have they got too much power I mean
do you see what I'm saying or am I being
I do I it's really difficult as a woman
knowing how I um go about this world and
being a specific sort of woman
um amazing
um but it's very it's very difficult to
then talk about
the impact on men I think I think a big
danger factor for men is porn I think
that's a big danger thing for society in
general uh let me just get that out of
the way
um
I think it's very difficult to talk
about male violence
and accept that most men are not going
to beat you up in your own home right
most men are not going to rape you on a
night out if they can
um and so these themes that we talk
about it's a minority of men
um
I've got three sons
I want my sons to be men and I've got a
A very wise person I know is a man
called Brian and he talks about
masculinity is your sword in your sheath
it's having all the power
knowing that you can use it but not
having to but it being very very
super aware to everybody that you've got
it
um
that's the masculinity that I'm really
attracted to
um I'll have a door open for me actually
every day of the week and heavy things
carried because I'm five foot one I
offered to carry a bag
it wasn't that heavy though that's why I
offered
um exactly sure
um
but
I do worry I don't know if I think that
this particular theme is all about
men being emasculated because I think
it's it's the height of I don't even
like toxic masculinity I think it's
mostly bull
but I do feel there is an element of
real toxic kind of at the peak of
masculinity is then like the ultimate
woman-hating thing you could do is
pretend that you are one
um
yeah I'm just I'm concerned
I'm a I'm somebody that doesn't cry very
much right I'm relatively stoic some
some horrible things have happened to me
in my life and I'm it doesn't break me
at all
if I think I've mentioned this before if
I had a husband that broke under I
wouldn't like that or not but then I'm
not gonna break no well I I get what I'm
getting at is
um it's a difficult one to discuss and
it's difficult for you because you're a
woman's rights campaigner that's your
focus I I guess what I'm saying is and
again Jordan Peterson mentioned this is
if you think strong men are dangerous
just wait until you see weak men oh I
agree with you you know what I just
don't know what a strong man it's very
it's it's a it's a difficult thing to
describe
what does the strong man look like I
think a strong man takes his
responsibility to the father very
seriously yes
um I think a strong man wants to protect
the mother of his children as well as
his children right and then my role is
to protect my children and maybe look
after my husband my role as a wife is to
serve him and his role as a husband is
to serve me and that will of course make
a difference in the way that we do that
because I had babies my role my
reproductive role is to have the babies
I can't possibly think that something so
important wouldn't have an impact on the
rest of my personality and life and I
mean even childless women
I think we have um
instinct which I like used to call like
Legacy memory which is we we bring the
experience of our ancestors not in a
kind of like come by our spiritual way
but just I believe that if you can have
Instinct that is informed in your genes
and you know how to do it then why
wouldn't you carry anything else from
previous
Generations why wouldn't it be sort of
in your blood and your bones so
I I do get you and I I think you're
right I just I just wonder if some of
the things that we had to change for
women to be considered equal because our
society is set up on the structure of
success and finance
so in order to have autonomy you have to
have money
but in order to have a baby you have to
rely on as a woman you have to rely on
somebody to provide that money
and I've got women like I wouldn't like
rely on my husband I was like well the
state then is that different is the
state not the patriarchy if you're
saying that your husband is I mean I'm
all up for relying on my husband for
cash
it suits me fine but so we had to
we had to get through some of the things
that genuinely did subjugate women yes
we had to get through it and we found
these particular Solutions and they're
not perfect by any stretch and maybe
this is the consequences yeah well this
is what this is what I'm getting at
right because the the progress inverted
commas that we've made over the last 60
years there's been some good things
about that but like when you start
pulling on the sweater you don't know
which lines are going to come out of it
and it just seems to me that what you're
talking about there's is considered
trans nowadays which is the idea that a
man and woman get together and have
children and look after each other in
different ways
um and you know Louise Pera I don't know
if you've you're familiar with her I am
she wrote a lovely article about me in
The Spectator yeah is that sarcasm no no
no yeah it was really nice yeah and her
book is is very good and I think her
book is basically making this point it's
like the sexual revolution had its
benefits but look at this not great
though
I mean I don't
I don't know too many women who have a
good time on a in a short relationship
quite yeah quite but that is now the
standard for young women
yeah I mean they're just they've been
both men and women have been coerced
into thinking that there is fulfillment
in
um numbers by the way you know what a
lot of women don't understand if I think
is that it's not good for men either no
it's really not it's really not it
doesn't make men happy there's there's a
small minority of men who who are happy
with it for a while and then eventually
they have kids and settle down with with
somebody but for most men it's not good
either no I don't think we think about
this I mean I just think about the
physiological kind of exchange that
happens if you like and um I do feel
women
that is beautifully
Society is telling them that actually
this is empowering this so nuts though
isn't it it's um
yeah I just
I sort of think
maybe I'm just very special but I I
and maybe it's I've got a good a good
strong ego and maybe that's for a
multitude of reasons
um but I've always been of the opinion
that I get to
um be happy I get to do things that I
want I don't have to fit in with other
people
um I can trust my instincts and I really
do I have a very heightened sense of
um instinctively like what is right now
I'm not saying I get it right every in
every single time but
if something doesn't feel right to me
I'll just go with it I'll just trust
that I'm that my my instincts no better
than my rational brain
and loads of people don't there's um
Gavin de back I think it is who does the
gift of fear
he'd be a great guest a great guest and
he does this gift Affair where he talks
about a lot of
nasty kind of people who want to harm
you they will rely on your sort of sense
of politeness to justify to yourself why
oh it's all right if I let him follow me
in through the you know the the shed
door at the bottom of the entrance oh I
won't ask
um so it's uh he talks about the gift of
fear as something that you know you
don't see a mice on a you don't see a
map go a mouse when a cat comes along
think or maybe they're friendly and they
just they just trust their instincts and
I think we've lost that someone sort of
ties into your well the entire thing of
your work really which is you're like
this you know we could be polite but
actually we need to protect this is that
where you're coming from on it yeah
pretty much I think um I talk about this
on my channel
most women you will meet have had an
episode an experience in which they're
in a toilet or a changing room
female only and then they hear a man's
voice
and it happened to me when I'd flown
back from the states a couple of years
ago
and uh a guy came in he wasn't speaking
English he went in the toilet next to me
he was really loud I don't know whether
he was talking on the phone or whatever
but I instinctively just did this
and I didn't
and then I'm waiting and it's quite a
long time and I'm just waiting and then
when I do stop breathing I'm like
just trying to breathe quite until that
door shuts and he's gone and I can hear
his footsteps walking away
you can't you can't pretend nobody can
tell me
that that changes if that male voice is
accompanied with Stilettos it's it's
just not true it probably makes it worse
in some ways
um
what do you think we don't try to focus
on personalities on the show generally
but we have somebody running to be an MP
in this country
uh Eddie Izzard
um
who I think said that we just don't I
can't remember the exact words but it
was something along the lines of it's
the 21st century you just what was it
exactly does anyone remember no I can't
remember what Eddie said it was
something along the lines of we just all
need to get not get with the program but
it was language of that type
do we need to go with the program no I
think Eddie needs to stop copy of my
look
um I'm going to run against him so if he
if he runs I'm gonna run as an
independent against him yeah and maybe
I'll have prosthetic limbs
do we need to get with the program no I
think Eddie Izard is um
definitely as an AGP he's talked about
it I I used to feel quite sorry for him
because it he he does talk about this so
I mean you might have to fact check it
but he was in a documentary where he
talked about his mother dying when he
was quite young and he looks for her
everywhere
and I do believe that is the the
instigation and the start of this
particular fetish
um
but no it's it's so offensive wearing
fake breasts and then calling yourself a
woman it's so offensive
I mean it's years ago that would just be
like a comedy sketch right a man wearing
fake breasts and now he's running for
Parliament
and bloody Russell Crowe was tweeting
about it or you make it crampy yeah come
on then let's have that let Eddie bring
the conversation because the beautiful
thing about so many of these
narcissistic men
is that they have no idea that when they
speak they reveal everything that I
can't possibly tell people
but if I just show them Eddie as our
talking and wearing fake breasts that
tells that tells people mostly
um all they need to know
I'd be interested to see that that
debate I mean it would make for
great content
we'll happily have you both on to talk
about yeah if you both stand we would
and we would be fair to both of you yeah
oh he was so funny brilliant just
brilliant I was so gutted one of the one
of the greatest comedians this country's
ever produced undeniably when he talked
about himself being a male lesbian and
no they're not they're not a woman's
clothes they're my clothes and all that
stuff and like like come on it's on tape
man you used to call himself on all
action transvestites I know I could I
used to like I could repeat his stand-up
because I absolutely loved him and I
just think it's like the Douglas Murray
analogy that he got the train got in the
station and he just crashed all the way
through yeah just ruined it you're like
no just back there but I not to talk
about him personally because I I
wouldn't want to be unfair but often
what happens with these men is the AGP
element of their fetish just gets
overwhelming in the end and where they
could sort of keep a check on it it does
become as like a huge compulsion
well if you both stand we would love to
have you both on for a genuine
discussion not a [ __ ] Fest or anything
but an actual conversation between two
people clearly feel very differently
about it I wonder if he would actually
because out of all the people I wonder
if because he's intelligent erudite I'm
sure he could construct he doesn't shock
a challenge no yeah it really doesn't so
if you're watching Fair debate the
opportunities there uh we can uh you can
come and talk about it
um Kelly jacking absolute pleasure to
have you back
um before before we go to our last
question actually I suppose the question
for me is what is the end goal of your
work what are you what does it look like
is it a set of laws is a public policies
what do you want
I want no more children to transition in
fact I would like to for there to be a
prevention on anyone being able to
transition uh without at least three
years of intense therapy post 18 so they
couldn't transition until they were at
least 21.
um preferably 28 because that's when
your brain is fully developed
um I want the gra to be totally scrapped
I don't want any such thing as a man
calling himself a woman-in-law or vice
versa
um I would that I've got quite list
um
I would like no more female language
used for men at at all like if you want
to do that in your private conversations
that's fine but no government
um no school no government no NHS no
nothing no official place in which we
erase women's language or replacement
men's language with women's
um
aside from that and I don't know a
Knighthood
but yeah it's just it's just I want us
to return to truth
um and not my truth or your truth just
the truth that's that's what I'm
interested in yeah lady Posey of turfton
and we always finish our interviews with
the same question which is what's the
one thing we're not talking about that
we really should be as a society and
we'll do some locals questions in a
second as well sorry well
last time I think that still needs to be
talked about but I will introduce
the concept of
parents for rights and parents
understanding what their rights are and
responsibilities which are first and
foremost to their children and not to be
sidetracked by what
experts or the state tells you is good
for your kids it's a very good point
um we're going to do a few of your
questions for locals that you've asked
on there that only you will get to see
so join us there but for now Kelly J Kim
thank you so much for joining us and
we'll see you very soon with another
brilliant episode like this one or also
all of them go out at 7 pm UK time and
for those of you who like your
trigonometry
take care and see you soon guys
I'm a teacher
teenage she teaches teenagers and have
some trans students trans and inverted
commas how would you address these goals
who are miners if you were in my
position
[Music]